Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan. Although you may
know me, across the Internet is Rawkode.
Today is the third episode of our Portainer
in production series.
Before we begin, I'd like to say thank
you to the team at Portainer who sponsored
my time to put this course together. It's
been a whole lot of fun. I'm really
enjoying using Portainer, and you're gonna see why.
So
what is on the menu for today?
Well, I wanted to see if I could
choose Portainer
with Equinix Medal
together
to deliver an application
to my customers
with as low latency as possible.
Now
I can do this with Equinix Medal
by using
global Anycast
BGP advertising
to route traffic to any region they support.
But it comes with a maintenance overhead.
I then need to manage bare metal in
Asia, The US, and Europe
continuously.
I need to update my applications. I need
to use something like SaltStack or Ansible to
push out updates to all of them at
the same time.
It's cumbersome. And in fact, this is why
we fall back to tools like Docker Swarm,
Nomad, and Kubernetes.
However,
those all bring a level of complexity as
well.
And I love Kubernetes.
I talk about Kubernetes all the time. However,
it's a pain in the ass when you
have to distribute it and scale it globally.
Kubernetes using etcd is a very chatty system,
and in fact, it's often encouraged and recommended
never to scale your Kubernetes cluster beyond a
single region.
So if I want to deploy an application
to my customers
all around the world with low latency,
Kubernetes
is not a good fit.
Now if I were doing microservices with thousands
of services, I'd maybe find a way to
make it work, but I'm not. I'm scaling
a few containers.
So
let's move all of this to a platform
designed
to do this properly,
and that is Portainer.
I'm gonna show you how to run Portainer
in an edge environment. Now I'm only using
three nodes around the world. However, Portainer scales
that has been tested to over 15,000
edge connections.
So it doesn't matter if you've got my
scale for a few people or your scale
for a few million.
So let's take a look at the code
to spin up and manage Portainer in an
edge environment all around the world on Equinix
Metal with any cast written using BGP.
This demo was super fun for me. I
hope you enjoy it. Let's dive right in.
Alright. So today,
everything that I'm going to show you is
available on the Portainer in production repository.
The link is in the description below.
We are using Terraform CDK
to automate the provisioning of four bare metal
devices.
One, Portainer admin node,
which will act as the central point for
distributing commands down to our edge agents,
and three edge agents, three bare metal devices
distributed around the world, all sharing one common
Anycast BGP advertisement.
This will allow us to request a simple
NGINX container
from anywhere in the world and see very
low latency response time.
Now I'm gonna spin this up in a
way that we see it with two edge
agents, one in The US and one in
Europe.
We'll see that the response time from Asia
and Australia
is pretty poor.
We're gonna bring in a third node,
and we're not gonna install anything to it.
We're gonna let Portainer do what Portainer does
best, which is manage all of these edge
devices for us using edge stacks. We'll then
rerun our tests, and we'll see that we've
substantially improved the latency to our customers in
that region. And that is the goal. Right?
We wanna be able to have ephemeral
automated compute infrastructure
handled for us with all our applications deployed
via Portainer with no manual intervention.
So let's take a look at the Terraform
CDK.
Now, we are gonna do this in a
two phase deploy. One to deploy the admin
node to get the token that we need,
which is the edge key here,
to then do the second part of our
deployment with the edge agents.
Now we've got the Portainer admin Terraform stack,
which uses Cloud init, and I'll show you
the scripts to do the provisioning in just
a moment.
To handle deploying Portainer as an admin node
and as an agent.
And then we have the Equinix provider so
that we can provision some bare metal devices
with a BGP advertisement.
We reserve a global IPv four address on
the Equinix metal network. We build our cloud
and a configuration,
and we deploy the device.
Now I am enabling a BGP session on
the admin node. We could in theory
double down and use that as a edge
compute node if we wanted. However, for today,
I'm not really doing that.
We use Terraform outputs to publish the admin
IP, so that we can get to the
web interface and the BGP IP, so that
we can request traffic or we can request
the NGINX application.
Next, we define the Portainer at the Edge
stack.
Now this also uses Cloud in it and
Equinix just like we do above.
The user data that we're generating Web Cloud
in it is just a little bit different
and that we are setting up BGP and
our Portainer agent instead of the Portainer installation
script.
Like so.
Then we provision the device. This time, we
are passing in the edge key and the
global BGP
IP address as custom data so that we
can fetch that back down from a user
data script.
And then we output the worker IP,
and we also configure the BGP session.
So this is not terribly complicated. It's just
a hundred and so lines of Terraform CDK.
You can pull this, you can run it
yourself, it should just work TM.
Now down here, we have defined our stacks
in Terraform CDK, but we actually need to
tell it what to synthesize and what to
run. So we generate the application.
We create the admin stack.
We can now have this new container at
the edge stack. We can actually duplicate this
as many times as we want to any
facility within or any metro or facility within
the network,
and it continues to scale out geographically as
much as we want. Perhaps we want more
infrastructure on the East Coast and the West
Coast Of The US. Perhaps we want infrastructure
in Central Europe, Western Europe, and how to
infrastructure distributed across Asia. That is up to
you. You know your customers,
and once you have the stack run up,
Portainer does all the heavy lifting. All you
need to do is spin up new nodes,
join a Portainer cluster, and you're you're golden.
And then we synthesize and we run it.
So we have no edge key here, so
I'm gonna walk you through the process of
spinning up the Portainer admin stack,
turning on edge compute, getting that key, and
then we'll take a look at the edge
deployment mechanism.
So first step,
as you'll see, I've already ran these commands
a few times, is to do a CDK
t f deploy
admin.
This will set up everything that we need
to get the edge key available for the
edge compute
deployment.
Now this is bare metal. It is not
a virtual machine on any of the hyperscalers,
So we're not gonna see this return in
ten seconds, thirty seconds, or even a minute.
It's gonna be closer to one to two
minutes.
So I'm gonna go poof,
now back in a second. Sweet.
We have our admin stack deployed. We have
our BGP address, which won't be resolving any
traffic at the moment. And we have our
admin IP, which will allow us to set
up our Portainer instance.
Let's copy our admin IP
and pop it open in our browser.
We will be presented with the Portainer setup
screen.
We've seen this before, so I'm not gonna
spend any time on it just now.
Provide my password. I hit go.
And I'm going to provide my license key.
Remember,
the business edition of Portainer is free for
up to five nodes.
So if you're a small scale deployment like
me, take advantage of that. Sign up now.
Okay.
Now that we have Portainer admin node running,
the first thing we wanna do is go
to settings.
From here, we can click on edge compute
where we turn on the edge compute features
and click save.
We then want to scroll down to the
automatic edge environment creation.
You will see your admin IP address and
port number here. You can disable the waiting
room if you want. However, we're going to
leave that on so you can see how
it works in this demo.
Now because I'm using my CDK
Terraform or Terraform CDK automation,
I don't need to worry about edge ID
generators
or dropping an environment variables into this script
here because
it's already done. So just go check out
that automation
and CloudEdit configuration scripts to see how I
generate those values.
The only thing I really want is this
edge key here.
So we're going to copy this and switch
back to Versus Code to drop it in,
like so.
From there, we can run a CDKTF
deploy,
and we're going to deploy
US and EU.
However, I also specify admin.
That's just because that The US and EU
stacks do have that dependency on the admin
stack, so it will force you to specify
all three.
We click the button,
we wait a few moments,
and we'll get an approval prompt for two
stacks to be deployed.
We had approved twice. Those devices are now
created on the Equinix middle platform, and I'll
be back in just a moment to show
you the next step.
Sweet.
We now have a worker IP in The
US
and a worker IP in The EU.
Now before I go to the browser and
show you the next step, I do wanna
push out one caveat.
If you're running the same automation and you
go to your browser, you may not see
the pending nodes right away.
The reason this is is that CDKFTF
is not waiting for the user data to
finish provisioning.
So while these bare metal devices are now
available and I have IP addresses,
the cloud in it process is probably still
running, and it can take anywhere from thirty
seconds up to a minute and a half
to complete.
That is because it's pulling down a Docker
image. It's then starting in the Docker image,
it has to register with the Portainer admin
instance blah blah blah blah blah. Now because
of the per video, when I go to
my browser, things are magically gonna be there.
Please just remember, it can take a few
more seconds.
And that being said, let's now go to
my Portainer admin instance. So we can click
on edge devices
and click on the waiting room.
And we'll see at the moment, I have
one of my devices waiting.
Hit refresh and by the power and magic
of video, now both are available. We can
now click on this and see that we're
happy to associate these devices with our Portainer
cluster.
Now where we click on edge devices,
we will see that we have Portainer at
the edge Frankfurt and Portainer at the edge
Dallas. This is our US and European
devices.
Now, Portainer has a cool feature where you
can enable groups.
This is not important for today's Edge stacks
demo. However, if you have more than one
administrator of your cluster,
you may be able to use groups to
be able to facilitate access to multiple edge
devices with ease.
To do so, I will create a group
called production,
and instead of saying this is static and
selecting the two machines, I'm gonna make this
dynamic, and I'm gonna base it on environment
variables. We can say environment production,
and we'll see that the two devices already
provisioned are now available to add to our
edge group.
Now, again, not important for the stacks demo,
but for managing access to more than one
edge device,
groups are super cool feature.
Next up, we're gonna add our edge stack.
So we go to edge stacks, we click
add,
and I'm gonna call this NGINX. We're gonna
use a very simple Docker compose file to
deploy NGINX to each of our edge location.
We then select the group of production
and the type of deployment will be composed.
Now if you go to the repository in
the description below, you will see that there
is a docker composed file.
You can copy this or type it. It's
very simple.
It's just going to deploy NGINX and expose
it on the host or node port of
8,080.
And then we say deploy.
You'll see here we have status indicators,
blue, green, and red. Let's turn on auto
refresh to ten seconds,
and you'll see now we have two successful
environments.
Blue for acknowledged and red for failed.
If we click on this
and then environments,
you'll see that this stack is successfully deployed
in both Dallas and Frankfurt.
Well, let's go back to our CDKTF
for just a moment.
We have this BGP advertisement
here.
So let's pop this open in our browser.
And if I browse to eighty eighty, we
are presented with the NGINX web page.
So let's check the performance of our application
using a nice web performance checker
from KeyCDN.
You can go to tools.KeyCDN.com/performance,
where you can drop in
your URL and port number and say test.
Now what we see here
is pretty standard for web applications,
especially deployed in this topology.
The latency for European and US websites is
pretty high in Asia and Australia.
You can see Frankfurt has
less than two milliseconds response time or at
least a connect time. We have less than
three milliseconds for time to first date.
This
is peak performance.
Now Amsterdam is gonna rise a little bit,
but you're still on the European continent and
the traffic is still pretty decent. And the
same for London.
Now New York being on the East Coast
is a little bit higher, but you can
see in Dallas,
at least where our infrastructure is actually hosted,
we've got less than four milliseconds on the
connect and five milliseconds on the time to
first pay.
Pop down to San Francisco, we've got the
West Coast. So if you're not sure where
Dallas is, it's in Texas. It's kinda right
in the middle. That's why both the coast
are a little bit slower.
Let's look at Singapore.
We're waiting over two hundred milliseconds
for the connect,
and we're waiting almost half a second for
time to first bite.
Sydney
is not much better. Two hundred milliseconds or
at least a hundred ninety milliseconds on the
connect with three hundred and seventy three milliseconds
on the time to first bite. Tokyo's high
and Bangalore is high.
So we can improve this performance,
and I'm not gonna do anything
except
for deploy our other stack.
Now the Terraform CDK will provision the instance
or cloud and it will install a Portainer
agent. Portainer stacks will detect
the new device.
We will approve it because we have the
waiting room turned on. However, you could turn
that off.
Once we approve that device, Portainer will realize
that it is part of
our stack configuration,
deploy NGINX, we'll be able to rerun the
tests, and everything will be super fast and
low latency everywhere we go.
Let's do it.
So let's do our CDK deploy,
and remember,
because
each of our edge deploys have a dependency
on the admin stack, we need to add
the admin stack too.
However, nothing will need to be deployed for
the admin stack, and that will just offer
us one change for our compute stack, which
is our Asian compute node.
So for the last time, I will be
back in just a moment.
Alright. It's almost time for the moment of
truth. We now have an IP address for
our Asian compute node.
So let's head over to the Portainer admin
interface and check out our waiting room.
And there we go. We have our Singapore
instance ready to be associated.
If we come to our stacks,
hopefully,
that the refresh is right, although it may
be a little too fast.
There we go.
We caught it. We have our acknowledged environment,
and I wait for the automatic refresh in
ten seconds or refresh it myself manually. We
should see that turn green.
Hey.
Love it when stuff works.
We can click on this, click on environments,
they're all okay.
And what I really love about this
is that we don't need to worry
too much
about the management layer of a geographically
distributed compute cluster.
This is something that Kubernetes is notoriously bad
at. Stretching Kubernetes clusters across more than one
region is super painful.
You pay a lot of money on egress
traffic because the communication patterns for the kubelet
and the API server
were built under the assumption that these things
were almost collocated within the same building.
Portainer
is different, especially with their edge compute semantics.
So we have to complete the demo. Let's
check key CDN to see the performance of
our application.
So I'm not going to change anything. It's
the same IP address, the same port,
but a different topology for our deployment.
And those numbers are looking pretty different already.
Singapore,
we have three and four milliseconds.
Of course, that is where we deployed the
other node.
Sydney is a little bit higher, but much
less than what it was without the Singapore
region.
And Tokyo and Bangalore have improved slightly as
well.
So that's pretty cool.
And this is one last thing we haven't
looked at, which is edge jobs.
Now that we have our geographically
distributed compute cluster
with our application being delivered to our customers
and a low latency environment using any cache
routing with BGP,
We may have admin things that we need
to run on a regular cadence,
and Portainer supports this through
edge jobs.
Now let's assume we wanted to run a
backup.
We can use cron syntax if we want
or the basic configuration.
We can mark this as recurring and say
run once per day.
From here,
we can use whatever script we want.
So if you need to backup any of
your volumes or your containers or logs to
Amazon s three or GCS or anything like
that,
script it away.
We can select the node or nodes we
wish to run it and click create.
As simple as that, we have our backups
good to go.
So that is the edge compute capabilities of
Portainer.
Coupled with Equinix Medal and BGP written, you
can get some pretty impressive architectures
to satisfy your customers wherever they are.
Join us for the next video in this
course. I'm gonna be diving deep into how
Portainer can enrich Kubernetes.
I'm very excited for the next video. I
hope you are too. I'll see you soon.
Until next time. Have a good day.